so when you my computer now says that we
are live
can you confirm that yes
we are live okay good evening everybody
i'll start again
good evening everybody nice to see
everybody
uh apologies the only apology i have at
the moment is councillor newport
are there any others
okay are there any substitute members
okay uh non-members attending
you i don't see any non-members
attending can you confirm that sonia
no non-members sir cancer
okay right members just before we move
on to
the minutes uh can i remind you that
part of the minutes are exempt documents
and need to be dealt with under private
confidential
so if anybody wants to raise any issues
under that particular
uh part of the minutes
uh we will need to go into private and
confidential
and can i also while we're on the
subject remind members
that the um update that we will receive
later we shouldn't be straining into
any sort of commercialization of the
situation because that again would be
uh need to come under private and
confidential so
members can i just remind you of that
okay you've all had copies of the
minutes um i will take it that
unless anybody wants to raise their hand
to raise either an issue or object
i will take that as read and as soon as
practical
i will sign the minutes off
i see no hands raised uh sonia can you
confirm that for me
that's right thank you
uh title five uh received in
excuse me to receive declarations of
interest
is there anybody is anybody members
forced to raise any
yeah i see no race ah that's what i knew
uh chairman i'd like to raise a
non-procuring
interest being the chairman of the
rochford chamber of trade
any any others and remind members if any
particular point comes up during the
course of the meeting
um please uh let me know as soon as
as practical and we'll make a note of
your
declaration of interest
item six uh update on the asset delivery
program
uh at which point i'm going to hand over
to matt harwood white
uh assistant director um who will
take us through the document
evening chairman evening members
hopefully you can hear me
clearly um i'll uh i'll just present
the report briefly thank you um chairman
uh this report this evening is for
noting
um and it provides a report on the
council's asset delivery programme
um specifically progress achieved since
uh the meeting full council
on the 19th of may um chairman as the
senior responsible officer for this
program um following that meeting
i have initiated negotiations with gb
partnerships
um our preferred bidder uh in
consultation with the portfolio holder
for enterprise
um as set out in the report chairman
the negotiations are seeking to confirm
the financial commitments
and the other terms contained in the
tender reports and the final business
case
as well as addressing the uh the matters
specifically referenced
in their preferred bitter letter at the
last meeting in the exempt appendices
chairman um assets out in the management
case
and the of the final business case a
partnership board has been established
and that consists of uh gb partnerships
rented
representatives uh and also senior
council
representatives uh including myself the
security director
the secretary 151 officer and the
portfolio holder for enterprise
um the partnership board is currently
operating in in shadow formats
until the contract is signed it had its
first meeting in june
and discussed progress regarding
negotiations of the three work streams
as
as set out in in the report gym
the role of the shadow partnership board
is to oversee the work of the
three work streams in order the contract
between both parties can be concluded
and once both parties are satisfied
there is a contract
which is acceptable to both of them this
will be set out in a further report
to a meeting of council in september uh
of this year although at this point the
formal date has not been yet set
that will happen once the um
negotiations have been concluded
um chairman that that concludes my brief
presentation
um and as you set out chairman the
report is for noting thank you
thank you uh mr white um i'll
take um i'll go to the members of the
working party and the shadow partnership
board
as to whether they wish to add anything
to the report
at this stage and then i'll go on to
questions
okay okay uh the first one hand up that
i have is councillor adrian eaves
over to you counselors
we can't hear you counselor reeves
apologies um thank you chap um
just one point really uh the we have an
item under risk implications
uh and the report states that the
risk is being managed and this is a live
document was continually being updated
i think it would be appropriate for this
committee if we actually
whenever we had a meeting if we had view
of that updated risk
risk document especially in light of
recent events and the possible
implication that it may have on council
finances
thank you
harvard white would you like to comment
on that
thank you chairman um uh yes accountant
says it's a live document and
um uh i'll be happy to um
share that with the with members as a
exempt document chairman
okay thank you for that okay
next person i have on my list here is
councillor stuart wilson over to you
councillor wilson
have thanksgiving michael yeah thank you
um
it's one question really it's about the
governance and the oversight of the
the um
typically for a program like this you
would do a gateway zero which is the
review of the strategic assessment in
other words what you're doing is on an
annual basis
you're looking to see whether you
actually still need the program
and my question really it's probably for
mr
harwood uh white and and for the
managing director
but given that we seem to have managed
our services
with officers working remotely
are we content and do we have the
evidence to say that
yes we still need the office
accommodation
that we're currently contracting for
mr harwood white would you like to pick
up on that
thank you chairman um the
this was a point that was discussed at
council um
in detail on uh pnc
um but i would point out that the asset
strategy
um as set out and is still um to be
delivered was
had three objectives around um
regeneration
transformation ongoing savings for the
council
um both of which uh wall street are
still
still relevant at this time and will be
kept under review but the strategy
itself is still valid is what the
officers are trying to um deliver
through this project jim
mr stratton do you wish to add anything
to that as md
um thank you chairman though i've got no
particular additional
you're a little comments fake can you
come back closer to the mic please
yeah apologies uh i'm usually accused of
of being too loud
uh can you hear me now yes that's fine
yes i've got no particular additional
comments to add to those that uh
matt howard white has has given them i
think the answer to the question
is is is yes
um you did have your hand up
um did you still want have a question
no uh council eve has actually uh
posed the same question which i'll which
i was going to address
councillor wilson uh you have your hand
up again
i think thank you chairman it's really
just come back on that point
will we actually um formally
accept what harvard white says but will
we
actually within the programme plan have
um
formal reviews including this gateway
zero
mr dwight would you like to respond
chairman um
the the final business case chairman was
agreed at
council um that's what we are seeking to
deliver
um the objectives of that business case
are on what this council needs to
deliver
and if we set out to deliver um
it is kept on the constant review um the
objectives of said chairman are still
for for us as a council to deliver
and as of as an officer team um i don't
talk about anything further chairman
this time
okay uh i don't see
any other hands is that any other
members wish to raise
any points
i'll give it a second just in case
okay members we do have a
recommendation on
page 6.3 of the reports
uh item 8.1 is proposed that the
investment board resolves
that the contents of this report are
noted
i will take it as accepted unless any
member wishes to put up their hand
to oppose that
give it a second just in case
okay members i think uh i have i think i
will accept that
as the report is julie noted
thank you very much for your time uh
that is the last item
on the agenda so thank you very much
indeed
and i will close the meeting at 1944
um a nice quick meeting compared to
others that we've had recently
so thank you very much for your time
angela law could you just hang on just
for a second once everybody has left